I want to play some clips for you of Jim
Jordan
Jim Jordan is a republican congressman
and Jim Jordan is interesting because
he is sort of the epitome
of the I say a lot of stuff but when it
comes down to it I don't really stand
behind the principles and when it comes
to Jim Jordan often those principles
have to do with a small government
conservatism so-called small government
conservatism and the claim from the
right that oh we don't want to regulate
we don't we want to let businesses do
what they want to do Jim Jordan appeared
last night uh no the night before last
with Sean Hannity and he seems to be
saying here that Apple should be
investigated because they've stopped
advertising on Twitter that's pretty
that's pretty that's several levels deep
when it comes to getting pretty involved
in the decisions made by private
businesses take a listen to this I think
there's some other critical questions
Sean we got to ask like why did Apple
change the features on phones in China
why do that for the CCP and and I think
the the other the other key Point here
is why uh why is Apple no longer
advertising on Twitter back some of
their ads have they gone woke so what I
want to know is where was the Apple
where's the Apple that a few years ago
said we're gonna stand up for Americans
privacy where's the Tim Cook who told
Jim Comey there is no way we're giving
the FBI backdoor access to people's
phones that's the Apple we want to see
because I again right now we know one
thing Sean the left is at war with the
First Amendment the left doesn't want
the First Amendment anymore and uh that
is that is the key concern here the left
now says this if you don't agree with
them you're not allowed to speak and if
you I think there's think about how
crazy that is okay
these are people
who want to tell businesses
you're pulling advertising from Twitter
because you don't like Elon Musk we
should investigate that
that's their free speech right those
businesses have the right to express
themselves by advertising or not
advertising wherever the hell they want
and they have the gall and the audacity
to say it's the left that's against
speech understand that all of these
actions being taken by people related to
Twitter are protected by Free Speech if
someone wants to protest Elon musk's
ownership of Twitter by quitting Twitter
that is their constitutionally protected
Free Speech right whether it's because
they're woke or not doesn't really
matter if you want to Lobby
companies that you patronize to stop
advertising on Twitter because you don't
like Twitter that's your free speech
right if I see that you know whatever
what company you know Frameworks is
advertising on Twitter
and I want to go to Frameworks and say
Hey you shouldn't advertise on Twitter
because of this that the other thing
that's my My Free Speech right and if
Gator Works Frameworks sorry Gator
Frameworks this is my mic stand if Gator
Frameworks says oh we want to ignore
what our customers are saying and keep
advertising on Twitter
that's their right and if they say
that's that's kind of an interesting
idea yeah maybe or some of our customers
are right we shouldn't advertise on
Twitter that's also their free speech
right this is all speech
and they claim it is the left that is
suppressing speech these people are
pathetic and by the way this we should
they should be worried if they start
investigating Apple what will happen
with all the investigations into Hunter
Biden that they have planned one other
clip from disappearance two nights ago
continuing to talk about Twitter take
Twitter off the App Store so there's
some good news there is it maybe because
Elon Musk threatened to compete with
with Apple
yeah well I I probably so but it sounds
like that meeting went well today let's
we'll find out tomorrow so let's hope
they're not going to kick Apple out of
the App Store but I think
imagine if 10 years ago even eight years
ago I told you in 2022 almost 2023
Republicans are going to be on Fox News
doing segments wherein they say hey you
know what we got to make sure that
Twitter doesn't get kicked out of
Apple's App Store and if they do we
might just have to investigate that
these people are truly something else
it's all small government it's all small
government make sure that you are
subscribed to the YouTube channel at
youtube.com slash the davidpackman show
we're going to take a quick break and be
back right after this
our sponsor magic spoon is the breakfast
cereal that tastes amazing but without
the sugar carbs and the crazy
ingredients magic spoon has taken your
favorite childhood cereals and
brilliantly transformed them into
something you can feel good about eating
because each serving has zero grams of
sugar under five net carbs and is packed
with 13 grams of protein so it'll work
for keto and low carb but it's really
perfect for anyone who wants the
occasional sweet crunchy treat without
the sugar their portfolio of eight plus
unique delicious flavors allow you to
never get bored my favorite is maple
waffle but they've got the classics like
cocoa fruity frosted also cinnamon roll
blueberry muffin our entire team has
been eating magic spoon for years we
love it but if you don't they send you
all your money back it's really easy
magic spoon has been supporting the
David Pacman show for a long time they
always give my audience five dollars off
when you go to magicspoon.com Pacman and
use the code Pacman the link is down
below